l'IGPN n'est pas déconnecté de la
réalité du terrain très clairement elle
ne l'est pas pour autant en toute
connaissance de cause y compris des
difficultés particulières auxquelles
sont confrontées les policiers de d'une
adversité réelle à laquelle ils peuvent
se retrouver confronté nous nous devons
de rappeler quand toute circonstances et
j'insiste en toute circonstances le
devoir d'exemplarité du par chacun des
policiers doit être rempli concrètement
en 2022 nous avons eu quatre
usages des armes mortelles
usage
situation opérationnelle d'usage des
armes alors je reviens sur ce chiffre de
62 ce chiffre comme vous avez pu le voir
peut-être dans notre rapport d'activités
paru c'est le plus faible qui enregistré
depuis plus de 10 ans cette maîtrise de
l'emploi de la force 62 usages des armes
seulement est à mettre un regard avec
l'importance croissante depuis 10 ans du
nombre de gendarmes agressés nous avons
eu
4354 agressions en 2022 ayant
occasionné
2462 blessés concrètement retenez qu'en
10 ans nous avons multiplié par deux le
nombre de gendarmes blessés en
intervention sur le nombre de procédures
judiciaires qui ont pu être ouvertes
dans la suite des émeutes liés au fait
dramatique à Nant sur le décès du jeune
Naël qui a pu être évoqué le nombre de
10 enquêtes judiciaires qui avaient pu
vous être communiquer et par essence si
j'ose dire caduque puisque il évolue et
que nous avons aujourd'hui 21 procédures
judiciaires en cours étant précisé que
sur les 21 sont de gravité et de nature
très différentes les unes d'entre elles
la problématique puisque par le terme de
refus d'obtempérer elle a pu être évoqué
des tirs sur les véhicules en mouvement
en 2022 nous avons eu 13 morts liés à
des tirs sur des véhicules en mouvement
et que nécessairement ça interroge ce
chiffre de 13 morts doit être mis au
regard d'éléments et que je veux ici
rappeler tant on entend tout et son
contraire sur une évolution qui serait
croissante sur les tirs sur les
véhicules en mouvement en 2021 157
sur tir sur des véhicules en mouvement
avec l'arme individuel en 2022 138 tirs
sur des véhicules en mouvement avec
l'arme individuelle ces chiffres sont à
mettre au regard parce que je me dois
d'être complète de deux morts en 2021 et
de 13 morts je l'ai évoqué en 2022
l'article
435-1 du code de la sécurité intérieure
issue de la loi de février 2017 tant
commenté ces derniers temps prescrit un
régime très strict et très précis pour
les policiers et pour les gendarmes
d'ailleurs puisque ce texte qui est un
texte spécial si j'ose dire de la
légitime défense pour les policiers et
les gendarmes indique que ils ne peuvent
être fait
usage de l'arme qu'en cas d'absolu
nécessité et de strict proportionnalité